[Music]
doesn't make
a dream
[Music]
screaming
[Applause]
fast baby
[Music]
tell me things
too short to last long
beautiful
[Music]
the Rhythm was set down
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
hope you enjoyed this video
um got an interesting idea in my head on
this one in that usually when we create
flow videos it's all about kind of
flattening uh the POI and our movement
in front of the camera and I thought
what the heck why not play with a little
bit of depth so how did it turn out
leave me a comment and let me know your
thoughts in the meantime I just wanted
to put out a quick thank you to ultra
POI for sponsoring this video and giving
me a reason to go out and try fun
experiments like this if you'd like to
grab a set of those orb POI Pros that I
was using in this video you can do that
by using the promo code drexfactory with
a zero instead of an O at checkout over
at ultrapoi.com that gets you a discount
on your order and it helps out the
channel so everybody wins thank you so
much Ultra POI for helping to make these
creative projects possible and speaking
of thank yous I have to thank the
friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca
flowfests flow toys pyro Terra light
toys juggling calling spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video that was a
weird little thing in my throat there
anyway
um also a special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel That
is Becca becklinen thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission finally this video would not be
possible we're not for the kind support
of all these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they have contributed to making
this channel possible so thank you one
and all for your very generous support
um if you'd like to check out other
videos I've created of myself doing all
kinds of flow I will include a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here because uh it's
popular amongst viewers of my channel so
maybe give that a look as well thanks so
much for watching have yourself a great
weekend get out and flow and I'll see
you with a new video real soon
peace